can we use logarithms to find the number
of digits in a to the power B say the
number is n let's represent the possible
values of n using a scale
now we make equal units with multiples
of 10 so that we cover a range from 1 to
10,000 so if the number a to the power B
is 9 it'll lie between 1 and 10 if it's
400 it lie between 100 and 1000 now what
if we find the log to the base 10 of
these numbers the log of 1 is 0 the log
of 10 to the base 10 will be 1 what will
be the log of 100 to the base 10 it will
be the log of 10 squared to the base 10
that will equal 2 times log of 10 to the
base 10 which equals 2 and similarly we
have 3 and 4 here now the important
question is why did we do this
let's see any number between 1 and 10
we'll have how many digits numbers like
35.5 9.8 they all have one digit to the
left of the decimal point
and if we look at the log scale we can
say that if the number has one digit
then it's log will be between zero and
one the logarithm will be of the form
zero point something okay now look at
the second part any number between 10
and 100 will have two digits correct
numbers like 22 49.1 have two digits and
their logarithm lies between 1 and 2
it'll be of the form one point something
we will have three digits and four
digits in these two paths respectively
and then logarithms will be between 2 &
3 & between 3 & 4 respectively now this
gives us a very important result 0 plus
1 is 1 1 plus 1 is 2 2 plus 1 is 3 and 3
plus 1 is 4 when 1 is added to the
number that we see in logs we get the
number of digits in the number we can
derive a very important property with
this if
log of n to the base 10 is of the form x
point something then the number n will
have X plus 1 digits to the left of the
decimal point this is how logarithms
help us find the number of digits in a
to the power B let's trout an example
there you go we have to find the number
of digits in this number and we have
been provided with these two logarithmic
values needless to say you aren't
allowed to use the calculator so let's
try finally the log of the numbers what
will this be equal to we can use the
logarithmic addition identity to
simplify this a bit log of a times B is
equal to log of a plus log of B applying
the identity the right hand side can be
written like this can be simplify this
further yes we can use the
multiplication by a constant identity
log of a to the power N is equal to n
times log a applying it to the first
term we get 12 times log 2 to the base
10 and applying it to the second one we
get 10 times log 7 to the base 10 and we
have been provided with these two values
substituting them here we get this
expression now these calculations are
pretty easy the first term can be
written as 10 times 0.301
plus two times zero points three zero
one three point zero one plus zero point
six zero two will equal three point six
one two and this will be eight point
four five one this sum equals twelve
point zero six three this is the log
value of this number n but is that what
we are asked for not really we are asked
for the number of digits in the number n
and the rule we just looked at said that
if the logarithm to the base ten value
is of the form x point something then
the number of digits in the number will
be x plus one as the number x is 12 here
the number n will have 13 digits before
the decimal